les discussions vont quand même très
rapidement pour forcer au tenté de
forcer le départ de donald trump
retrouvons notre expert de politique
américaine charles philippe bonsoir
bonsoir ses livres alors on vient
d'entendre donald l'homme qui reconnaît
là qu'il ne sera plus là le 20 janvier
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour calmer
le jeu après vous il tente de sauver sa
peau ça c'est très clair parce qu'il
sent que l'eau est très chaude
déjà j'ai le goût de vous dire ce
discours qu'il a lu ce soir qui n'est
pas vraiment de lui et qui ne vient pas
de ses tripes ils auraient pu le
prononcé depuis au moins un mois
en promettant donc une transition
pacifique mais là je pense qu'il sait
que tout le monde est à ses trousses mon
sein de son cabinet autour de lui ses
conseillers politiques des membres ont
démissionné et au congrès
non seulement les démocrates sont
évidemment outré mais le parti
républicain commence à se fissurer
plusieurs voix se font entendre
certaines ont été très vocal aujourd'hui
pour réclamer sa démission
oui alors ça reste encore quelque chose
qui va être discutée dans les prochaines
heures et les prochains jours je crois
au delà de cette vidéo
alors dites-nous qu'est ce qui est
vraiment possible parce que plusieurs
scénarios possibles jean-françois les
évoqué commenceront par le 25e
amendement la de la constitution le 25e
amendement d'abord eh bien ça repose sur
la décision que prendrait mike pence le
vice président avec une majorité des 15
secrétaires
on les appelle ministre aux états unis
qui donc en majorité avec ma copine
s'acheminerait au président de la
chambre des représentants et au
président pro tempérées du sénat dont
notamment lundi pelosi une lettre qui
explicitement informe le congrès des
états unis que le président n'est pas en
mesure d'exercer ses fonctions et n'est
plus habilité à exercer le pouvoir
inapte à gouverner et la partir de ce
moment là une fois que cette lettre
déposée céline le vice-président devient
président par intérim
à moins que le président entre hommes ne
contestent cette évaluation ou cette
lettre qui a été envoyée en envoie une à
son tour qui contestaient encore une
fois par un deuxième avis
donnée par le vice président à la
majorité donc du cabinet est là après ça
c'est le congrès à raison de deux tiers
de majorité par chambre chambre des
représentants sénat par ailleurs qui
doit décider dans les 48 heures du sort
du président des états unis et du
président par intérim
donc pour le moment ça n'a pas l'air
très possible parce que mike bensalem
s'opposer à ce scénario
donc est ce que une destitution parce
qu'on parle aussi du cci possible alors
qu'il reste seulement 12 jours mais
voilà vous avez raison commencez d'abord
par le scénario du 25e amendement parce
que si le plus rapide qui peut être mise
en oeuvre
le scénario de la décision je pense tout
le monde s'en souvient on s'en souvient
bien en février dernier c'est un long
processus
alors je pense bien que lundi pelosi
veut convaincre tout le monde que la
chambre des représentants pourrait
peut-être voter en un jour un article de
destitution fondée uniquement sur le
comportement dix criminels de dans le
crabe et à raison avec ces déclarations
pour encourager incité son mouvement a
attaqué au fond le capitole mais après
il reste quand même céline au sénat
délibéré et voté le renvoi du président
des états unis je ne sais absolument pas
si une telle chose pourrait être
possible avec les jours qui restent mais
voyons là plutôt un symbole je pensais
que la colère est tellement grand que je
pense au sein de la classe politique s
est pas tout le monde qui évidemment
ouvertement manifeste cette colère mais
je pense qu'elle est là qu on veut
probablement envoyer un signal un signal
très clair qu'un président des états
unis ne peut pas inciter à une telle
violence
et malgré sa petite contrition
d'aujourd'hui ne pas être reconnu
coupable ce qui s'est passé hier
et puis par ailleurs je dirais il ya
quand même un avantage pour les
démocrates évidemment si dans notre en
pet être destitué je vous donne la
réponse tout de suite c'est que dans le
crâne ne pourrait pas se représenter en
ce qui serait quand même quelque chose
rapidement charles-philippe hésitent à j
se retrouve vraiment divisée comme
andrew bynum va-t-il pouvoir gouverner
réparer les pots cassés nous reste 30
secondes
oui ben je pense que c'est un pays cassé
c'est une démocratie cassé je vais
l'appeler le virus trump heures
man infecté tout le système politique
américain joe biden peut certainement y
allait de plein de projets de loi mais
ce qu'ils doivent surtout réparer c'est
le discours brisé civique qui n'existe
plus aux états unis et qui a entraîné
cette hyper polarisation joe biden va
vraiment avoir toute une mission devant
lui et je pense à me paraît extrêmement
difficile je pense que ce pays ait
durablement en plus qu'à diviser pour un
bon moment
oui ce sera pas facile pour dubaï d'un
merci beaucoup charles philippe jean
prix